al caer la noche en dakar llegaron
informes contradictorios de la coalición
gobernante y de la oposición
los partidarios del alcalde de la
capital que también es líder de la
oposición estallaron con canciones y
bailes e incluso el propio bate de mijas
desfiló por las calles cientos de
personas salieron tras ver los supuestos
resultados en internet personal
magnífico se destaca vi los resultados
en instagram es excelente realmente
excelente estamos muy muy contentos
vamos a estar de fiesta toda la noche
aunque el recuento sigue en marcha y no
se han publicado las cifras oficiales
los partidarios de ambos bandos
reclamaron la victoria eso incluye a la
propia jefa de la coalición presidencial
[Aplausos]
ganamos 30 departamentos de los 46 que
tiene el país
[Aplausos]
esto nos dará sin duda la mayoría en el
parlamento
la oposición remachó estos comentarios y
el alcalde de dakar dijo que la
cohabitación era inevitable los comicios
del domingo eran una prueba clave para
el presidente macky sall después de que
en las elecciones locales de principios
de año la oposición obtuviera triunfos
en varias regiones como ocurre en gran
parte del mundo senegal sufre un aumento
de la inflación y del coste de la vida
algo en lo que se centró en la campaña
la asamblea que vamos a elegir debe
ayudar a la población los diputados
deben hacer todo lo posible para reducir
el coste de la vida y permitir que los
jóvenes se encuentren trabajo para que
senegal pueda desarrollarse las
elecciones parlamentarias deciden de los
165 escaños del parlamento nacional para
los próximos cinco años la oposición
también ha dejado claro que quiere
impedir que mcchrystal se presente como
candidato a un tercer mandato algo que
prohíbe la constitución los resultados
provisionales se esperan máximo para el
viernes